c'est comment un visage sans visage et
ben c'est un vous avez juste le
squelette et les deux yeux
nous accueillons le professeur Laurent
Lantieri bonsoir
alors
professeur Laurent Thierry vous êtes
chirurgien en plastique vous avez réussi
la première greffe totale du visage au
monde et vous êtes ici ce soir pour
répondre à la question que tout le monde
se pose est-ce que oui ou non Franck
Ribéry c'est un essai
et les Bogdanov
c'est pas mes passions
chaque visage à une histoire où vous
parlez de votre parcours et vous
raconter heure par heure la première
greffe totale de la face effectuée sur
Jérôme Hamon que nous recevrons comme
invité à 20h alors vous êtes né le 15
février 1963 à Paris votre père André
officier de marine puis directeur
financier chez IBM votre maire Félicie
fait un peu foyer
voilà alors dès votre plus jeune âge
vous voulez devenir médecin quand je
serai grand je serai docteur pour vous
c'est une évidence c'était comme ça
c'était viscéral j'avais envie de faire
ça et votre illumination viendra lors de
votre quatrième année de cursus à
l'hôpital Boucicaut dans le 15e quand
vous rencontrez le professeur vilain le
créateur de SOS ma l'un des pionniers de
la chirurgie reconstructrice oui tout à
fait je voyais des bouts de doigts
arrivés sur la glace et puis trois
heures après une fois qu'on est tout
chercher ça devenait rose c'était vivant
c'était merveilleux c'était fantastique
et j'ai dit c'est ça que je veux faire
je veux réparer les corps comme ils le
font là alors en concours pour
l'internat vous êtes 50e sur 3000 pas
mal vous choisissez la chirurgie et
après quelques hôpitaux parisiens vous
partez vous perfectionner aux États-Unis
oui allez à l'extérieur m'a permis de
revenir et de prendre du recul par
rapport à tout ce qui se passait j'ai
passé un an dans un dans une ville qui
s'appelle sainte Luis à la jonction du
Mississippi et du misory ce milieu de
nulle part il y a rien à y faire si ce
n'est qu'il y a une grande université
américaine et quand vous allez voir le
doyen de l'université vous voyez tous
les prix Nobel qui sont passés par là
c'est une expérience extrêmement
importante le problème c'est que juste
avant de partir vous rencontrez
Dominique c'est pas un problème bah si
c'est un problème parce que comme elle a
pas de visa vous êtes obligé de
l'épouser quand même
et vous êtes toujours ensemble et bah
oui bah tout va bien
[Musique]
au retour vous entrez à l'hôpital Henri
Mondor de Créteil vous resterez jusqu'à
lundi dernier et désormais vous avez à
l'Hôpital Européen Georges Pompidou oui
absolument alors en 2002 à 39 ans vous
êtes nommé professeur de médecine et
vous commencez à multiplier les grèves
partielles notamment sur des patients
ayant tenté de se suicider par les armes
oui c'est malheureusement une pathologie
rare mais qui laisse des dégâts
absolument catastrophiques c'est de la
recherche clinique c'est à dire que le
patient n'est pas l'objet de notre
recherche il est le sujet de la
recherche c'est lui qui choisit je veux
y aller avec un environnement médical un
environnement bien sûr les techniques
chirurgicales immunologie du personnel
et puis aussi un événement psychiatrique
pour l'accompagner en 2005 les
professeurs du vauchelle et du Bernard
vous double sur le poteau et réalise la
première greffe de la face au monde sur
Isabelle dinoir vous vous leur aviez
fait parvenir vos protocoles de
recherche et ce de votre équipe il y a
une polémique dans les médias je pense
qu'ils sont pas très bien comportés mais
je dirais que c'est ça a été une ça a
été une blessure une blessure profonde
pas tellement oui par avoir été doublé
parce qu'on veut toujours être le
premier c'est dans la vie voilà mais
c'est surtout la manière ça s'était
passé tout ça ne comprenait pas
exactement comme je voulais le faire et
puis surtout j'avais des craintes de pas
de pas pouvoir recommencer derrière et
puis en fait je suis avec je bouge j'ai
continué à me battre à vouloir faire ses
greffes et j'en ai fait plus aussi la
première greffe de phase totale
c'est-à-dire celle qui comprend les
paupières et le système lacrymatiques
fonctionne voilà alors le récit que vous
faites de cette greffe dans votre livre
est absolument
époustouflant votre patient Jérôme maman
donc nous recevrons est atteint de
neurofibromatose ou la maladie de
reclink House alors c'est prononcez bien
c'est horrible parce que non seulement
ça vous transforme en éléphant man mais
en plus on fait des fautes d'orthographe
quand on écrit le nom de la maladie quoi
alors Jérôme est en attente depuis six
mois de cette greffe de face quand le
donneur est signalé à Lyon et à 1h du
matin dans la nuit du 26 au 27 juin 2010
vous partez pour prélever la face
absolument première chose vous l'avez
dit pour faire une greffe il faut un
donneur et les gens qui nous regardent
ce soir il faut bien qu'ils comprennent
que toutes ces grèves les grèves de cœur
les grèves de foie les greffes de reins
ne sont possibles que parce que on a on
a du des dons d'organes que les patients
ont accepté que les familles acceptent
et ça c'est important il faut que les
gens en parlent entre eux pour que ça
puisse être possible mais moi je le dis
je donne ma face si quelqu'un veut ça
c'est plutôt le problème
alors
à l'hôpital Édouard Herriot au moment où
vous allez rentrer dans la bloc
opératoire pour prélever la phase du
donneur vous avez le trac quoi comme un
acteur qui rentre en scène ou un
animateur qui commence une émission bah
oui c'est une intervention chirurgicale
d'abord en plus elle a une nature un
petit peu exceptionnelle bien évidemment
il y a toujours des impondérables des
aléas c'est quand même parmi les
premières que l'on faisait c'est très
difficile mais chaque fois qu'on rentre
au bloc opératoire il y a un instant un
petit peu de concentration qui au moment
où on se lave les mains c'est au moment
où on repense dans sa tête comment va
devrais se dérouler à l'intervention
pendant cette intervention contrairement
à d'habitude vous parlez pas avec les
autres chirurgiens oui d'habitude dans
une intervention chirurgicale il y a
beaucoup d'automatismes les fort
heureusement parce que sinon on
tiendrait pas et donc là à ce moment-là
on peut parler lorsqu'on ferme lorsque
on démarre l'intervention ça est
possible il y a des moments souvent de
concentration on ne parle pas moi j'aime
bien avoir un petit fond musical quand
j'écoute un peu moins fort que ce qui
est là mais du jazz quand même mais
là ce jour-là on a on a non c'est
rigolait pas alors vous prélevez la
phase donc comme n'importe quel autre
organe c'est un organe il a quand même
vous dit que l'image est apocalyptique
c'est comment un visage son visage et
ben c'est un vous avez juste le
squelette et les deux yeux et c'est tout
vous connaissez la série de films qui
s'appelle Freddy oui ça ressemble un peu
à Freddy quoi
heureusement le résultat est un peu
meilleur que ce que fait hier alors là
il y a un prothésiste en fait qui met un
faux visage pour les proches qui vont le
voir une dernière fois avant
de comprendre que nous tenons à
restaurer le donneur pour pouvoir le
rendre à la famille même quand il y a
pas de famille nous le faisons quand
même c'est une marque de respect
vis-à-vis de la personne qui a donné
donc il y a prothésiste qui vient on
fait d'abord un moulage et puis va dans
une autre salle et il prépare et quand
il le remet derrière c'est vraiment si
méprendre alors au matin la dissection
est terminée la face donc prélevée et
mise dans un sac rempli d'un liquide de
conservation et placer dans une boîte en
plastique absolument
Bron avec le avec le visage dans une
boîte oui c'est pas différent de
transporter un froid le problème c'est
qu'il faut se dépêcher quand même le
temps presse vous entrez au bloc
opératoire à 12h30 et puis donc vous
posez la face du du donneur sur le
squelette de Jérôme qui lui a été
préparé depuis la veille
et alors ce qui est extraordinaire vous
rebranchez l'artère et à ce moment-là
les veines se gonflent de sang le visage
revient à la vie et reprend des couleurs
ça doit être un moment magique cet
instant là j'ai pu sentir ce que Bernard
avait ressenti quand elle fait sa
première guerre cardiaque quand le cœur
est reparti c'est un peu la même chose
on voit une surface d'une blancheur
cadavérique que l'on pose on rebranche
l'artère et puis d'un seul coup ça se
recolore on se dit ça y est la vie est
là
alors voilà débuter à une heure du matin
la grève se termine 20h plus tard vous
dites celui qui fait quoi bah oui
complètement prenez des trucs faudrait
demander à Yannick Noah peut-être qu'il
a peut-être des trucs pour moi
non rien du tout non alors 48 heures
plus tard la mère de Jérôme arrive à
l'hôpital elle rentre dans la chambre
elle dit oh c'est magnifique et ce qui
est encore plus touchant c'est qu'elle
dit on le reconnaît c'est tout à fait
fascinant parce que parce que le visage
était gonflé on pouvait même pas voir
ses yeux il était très différent de tout
ce qu'il avait été il pouvait
difficilement parler puisqu'il avait une
canule il pouvait pas parler et là la
mère s'exprime comme ça c'est c'était
vraiment l'expression de l'amour de la
mer parce que c'est ni l'ancien visage
de Jérôme et pour cause ni le visage du
donneur parce qu'il est sur un squelette
différent donc c'est un visage unique en
fait on essaye en faisant ces greffes de
sortir de la normalité je sais pas si
qui ont des déformations ou qui ont des
séquelles d'un traumatisme pour les
remettre dans la normalité le plus
possible même s'il y a des défauts même
si ça bouge pas tout à fait pour qu'ils
puissent avoir une vie sociale alors
quand Jérôme accepte de se voir c'est
pas tout de suite il est toujours
incapable de parler ou de sourire et
pour vous montrer sa joie et son
soulagement il fait comme ça mais tous
les patients d'ailleurs on fait ça parce
que tout sont une canule et c'était un
geste de tous les patients les recettes
que j'ai fait ont tous fait ça alors
quand une greffe est réussie c'est quand
le patient doit dire bonjour vous êtes
qui en se voyant dans la glace quoi
c'était intéressant c'est quand il se
regarde dans la glace ce que disait
surtout Pascal le premier que j'ai fait
très rapidement il rêve de lui-même avec
son nouveau visage et donc ils oublient
complètement l'ancien donc il se
l'approprie comme ça alors trois
semaines après la grève Jérôme commence
à parler un mois après la greffe il est
autorisé à partir en week-end génial et
c'est vrai qu'il a essayé de partir sans
vous payer en disant que c'était pas lui
non il y a eu
il y a eu un problème il y a un problème
c'est que la sécu voulait pas payer son
transport ah ouais donc il a pris le
train comme tout le monde en vérité
Jérôme parlera de la greffe comme
l'expression
ultime de l'humanisme oui j'ai découvert
d'ailleurs mon patient à cette occasion
la meilleure aussi s'exprimer plus après
et j'ai trouvé ça vraiment une formule
qui était très extraordinaire alors nous
retrouverons Jérôme le premier greffé
total de la face à 20h et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu